harrison's lying you can't handle the
fact that harrison is a hero
that was always your wet dream
[Music]
and you can't stand the fact that he's
living it hey guys pete here this will
be my breakdown for dexter new blood
episode 4. h's for hero moved things
along quite a bit and left the
impression that we're past the table
setting portion of the season things are
officially getting interesting now with
a lot of new information to consider in
this video i'll recap everything that
happened and then talk about what stood
out to me and what i'm thinking about as
far as where this is going and we'll get
into all of that after a quick spoiler
warning if you haven't watched new blood
episode 4 yet then this video won't be
for you and with that out of the way
let's get into it the fourth episode
opens the morning after dexter
incinerated matt's body only to talk to
kurt who told him that he facetimed with
him and that he wasn't dead after all at
his cabin deb and dexter are talking
about why he might lie dex thinks maybe
he's upset he doesn't want to believe it
he's delusional and deb thinks maybe he
doesn't trust the cops and he wants to
take things into his own hands she
points out how enraged he looked
whenever he saw the video that someone
else was out in the woods and says that
he probably thinks that johnny bullhorn
one of the seneca tribe members murdered
matt for shooting the deer and that
angela is protecting him based on what
the characters know at this point it's a
fine theory but it's all undermined for
us as viewers by the end of the episode
we see harrison wake up and he uses the
term [ __ ] nuggets when he's talking
about the wrestling team and this leads
to a conversation between the two about
aunt deb who used to use that same
saying it's funny because dex says that
she's in my thoughts all the time but it
kind of stood out how they were talking
about her and more specifically about
harrison's memories kirk comes into the
police station and can't answer many of
angela's questions he wasn't sure where
he was but it looked like a hotel room
and he says that matt told him that he
was in new york city and he tries to
change the subject saying that if it's
about the deer being killed on seneca
lands he'll pay for it he always cleans
up after matt's messes but she points
out that that's not her jurisdiction she
wants to talk to matt for herself she's
been trying to call and his phone just
goes straight to voicemail and even
though kurt didn't want to bring it up
he tells her that it looked like matt
was high and that he hadn't slept for
days he does this sometimes he goes on
benders and weeks or months could pass
with them not talking to each other he
tells her that matt asked for money and
he turned him down and that he wasn't
answering any of his calls after that
either after he leaves molly comes to
her office she's there talking to logan
they hooked up and at first angela acts
put off because she volunteered to help
for the search saying she was a
concerned citizen and not letting on
that she was actually a podcaster as
they go back and forth it's obvious that
she's paying close attention to the case
and that she's there sniffing around for
clues or answers she's a fast talker she
has no filter so she's basically a
perfect podcaster and you can see that
she's making some good points and that
angela is taking notice before she
threatens to arrest her for interfering
with an investigation if she doesn't
leave the whole thing feels like there's
a team up that's gonna happen and when
she comes back later in the episode and
starts making martinis in her office
that starts to come together she gives
her a folder and starts talking about
all the girls on her carry from homeland
board and it turns out she posted
pictures on her instagram and found out
one of the girls was just a runaway when
her followers tracked her down other
ones she posted didn't get any leads at
all which means they're really missing
and that no one's looking for them
except for angela she wants to know what
her theory is because she knows she has
one here we get part of the explanation
of who iris was it was her best friend
in high school who disappeared and
everyone in town just said that she ran
away no one looked for her at all so
when angela became a cop she promised
herself that she'd be different she
started collecting these women's stories
and says that she knows in her gut that
something's happening here and when
molly throws it out there that they
should form an alliance angela says if
you want to help me shed light on these
girls i'll take it initially angela
didn't care much about what molly said
about matt but she did care about what
kurt said and she told logan to run
matt's cards again because he said that
he's staying in new york city in a hotel
there should be some evidence of that
somewhere
at the school harrison's texting with
audrey who sent him molly's podcast
which is called mary [ __ ] kill he
scrolls through the episodes it's all
the famous serial killers and he stops
at the one about trinity he starts to
listen and fast forwards to his last
kill and as he listens to the story of
his mother's death he looks pain to hear
about how as a young child he was left
alone in a pool of her blood and she
tops it off by saying how [ __ ] up is
that kid now am i right then it cuts to
dexter at the store and we see him get
an emergency alert on his phone it's
about the high school being on lockdown
as he's rushing in he sees that ethan's
being rolled out on a stretcher covered
in blood and he's reunited with harrison
who has a stab wound there's blood
everywhere and we can see dexter putting
the scene together in his head as he's
doing that angela asks about a potential
school shooting and harrison explains
that that's how it all started ethan
told him he wanted to get revenge
against the kids who were bullying him
and that he was going to bring guns to
school he told him because he wanted him
to do it with him and then he describes
how he got stabbed having turned the
tables slashing ethan's leg he sounds
sincere but it feels suspicious he's
worried that ethan might die and he goes
on to tell them that the knife came out
of his backpack when logan goes and
looks inside he finds all those drawings
which seem to back up harrison's story
when dexter asks him how he's doing at
home he says that he's messed up and he
asks for advice on how to deal with it
and dexter really doesn't do anything to
help he's kind of speechless and it's
awkward and harrison just ends up
brushing it off saying that he's fine
after he leaves deb comes in saying that
his son's not like him and that's going
to make it hard for them to have a
relationship when dexter's helping him
with the wound the next morning he
starts asking some questions harrison
immediately gets defensive and dexter
tries to brush that off by saying sorry
it's just my old forensics brain is
kicking in in his defensiveness harrison
gets angry and goes outside and dexter
tells deb that the stab wound doesn't
match the story something's definitely
off and she stands up for him saying
that he's normal and sometimes details
get mixed up it's a high intensity
situation and when dexter says that he
hopes that she's right she asks the
question do you harrison goes to the
hospital where he talks to ethan's
parents he's still sedated he definitely
would have died if the paramedics hadn't
gotten there fast enough and his parents
are angry they're in a bad situation all
the way around his father does tell
harrison that they appreciate what he
did because it could have been a lot
worse but they never want to see him
again and when he hears that and you see
him going through it in his mind he
looks absolutely crazy
dexter goes to the police station trying
to get more details about the
investigation while he's talking to
angela audrey hears that she was an
intended victim and comes into the room
and that leads to her taking a picture
of his kill list and the drawing where
he crossed out several students while
they aren't looking then he goes back to
the crime scene he tells deb that the
stab wound and blood spatter don't match
up with his story and she maintains her
position of trying to back harrison up
he reenacts the situation and what you
see there is that ethan was trying to
get away and harrison attacked him from
behind then he stabbed himself to sell
us on this story making it look like he
planned the whole thing why would
harrison slash ethan first is the
question dexter answers he wanted to
know what it felt like it's almost like
ethan fit the code
the next morning after harrison tells
him that he wants to get back into a
routine kurt shows up and he says that
he wants to show his appreciation to
iron lake's hero it's kind of strange he
gives him a drone which he would have
seen him flying the one the police had
outside the cabin the other morning so i
guess he picked up on that and after
harrison leaves kurt tells dexter that
it must be nice having a hero for a son
he says how matt was the opposite how he
wished he would have done things
differently and they get into a whole
conversation
where the boat accident gets brought up
all of this leads to kurt saying that
you'll see if harrison ever does
something wrong it'll be hard not to
feel responsible for it after he leaves
dexter thinks that he was fishing and
that he just nibbled at the station he
finds out that the police aren't
bringing charges against harrison it's
been ruled self-defense no matter what
ethan tried to claim it turns out that
after he woke up he swore that he never
stabbed harrison so she suggests that he
might want to get a lawyer for a civil
case against ethan but he's not
interested and she says she doesn't know
if she could be so compassionate in his
situation and after looking at the
photographs of ethan's injury dexter
comes to the conclusion that harrison
had his own knife kurt had had some
interactions with a girl who was camped
out in the truck stop he spoke to her
earlier in the episode where apparently
he gave her some money so when he talks
to her again after she didn't leave he
offers her a job instead so she can make
her own money she's not interested
though because she's trying to leave
town at the high school logan came in to
talk to all the students that were on
ethan's list and since harrison's there
dexter uses this time that he's a way to
search his room he eventually gets up to
talk to the other students after they
applaud him for stopping ethan he points
out how they had picked on him and beat
him up for years he says i know we're
all victims but everyone's calling ethan
a psycho or a monster but he was also a
victim and his point is that everyone
has two sides to them a little bit hero
and a little bit monster it's all about
what side wins out at the end and for
where we're at right now he's definitely
talking about himself right we see
audrey watching him and it looks like
she's definitely in love and while
that's going on we see kurt drive the
girl who was in his truck stop to the
cabin where the other one was and at the
same time in a hollowed-out old
flashlight dexter discovers harrison's
knife it's a straight razor exactly like
the one trinity used to kill his mother
rita and this leads to deb saying that
he was born in blood and to that dex
responds he has my dark passenger and as
he looks at the knife and he absorbs
this information it looks like he's
relieved about it and that's where we're
at
it's a strong ending to cap off the
introduction to dexter's new life in
iron lake and it pulled me right into
this revival the way all three of these
scenarios harrison's situation dexter
finding the knife and kurt being
revealed as being connected to the
missing girls the way they were all
playing out simultaneously has me
excited for how things will ramp up i
have to say i was properly surprised at
the twist of the school shooting
scenario they got me through the name of
the episode h is for hero that's been
out there for a couple of weeks and by
leaning in on harrison's sense of
justice and his standing up for the
bullied kid in the last episode plus him
having a dark passenger is such a bonus
for dexter it solves all his problems in
a scenario where they can connect
because they have this thing in common
it's not great if your son has the
makings of a serial killer unless you
are literally a serial killer like
dexter and i'll just throw it out there
that it seems a little bit too
convenient it fits into what dexter
wants to believe which makes it
suspicious on the one hand harrison did
a pretty good job of lying about what
happened to the cops he knew the
drawings were in ethan's bag and that
those would go a long way towards
backing up his story on the other the
slashing looked impulsive and not well
staged if there were any real
investigation into what happened so the
lying and the thinking on his feet and
using that scenario to cover up what he
did he looks pretty solid in that regard
and he did see all these drawings before
which means that it could have been
premeditated however they showed him
listening to the podcast just before
this which reinforced the idea that he
should be a messed up person molly laid
it right out there and that probably set
him off then you have the fact that he
does own a straight razor that looks
exactly like the one that killed his
mother so overall i would say that they
did a pretty good job of stoking up the
fire for either side of this idea that
you're on is he already a killer is he
like his dad is there no hope for him or
did he just flip out on the curt side of
things he didn't really sell the story
about matt calling him and i guess on
some level he doesn't know that his son
is actually dead there's a good chance
but there may be a part of him that
thinks that he just ran away and so he's
hoping that he might still show up it
was pretty confusing about why he would
lie if he wasn't trying to shut the
investigation down to protect himself
seeing him at the cabin with this new
girl appears to confirm that and like i
said i never really thought that this
might be somebody else that was doing
this there may be other people involved
but they didn't try to disguise clancy
brown's face or anything whenever they
were leading up to this so that
definitely looks like him in those
scenes him showing an interest in
harrison's also interesting because
something has to happen in order for
dexter to get on to the fact that
there's something going on with kurt
obviously he's interested about why he's
lying but he needs to figure out what's
going on in order for kurt to become the
kind of threat that will be necessary
for him to take him out that connection
with harrison might have something to do
with it and where we're at now there's a
lot of things that could go wrong for
team dexter here the crime scene doesn't
back up harrison's story if anyone looks
into it at all they're gonna come to the
same conclusion that dexter did and
where they're at now he has every reason
to believe that he wouldn't be able to
tell his father the truth he put the
story out there now he has to stick with
it then we also still have dexter on
those thermal images and he lives really
close to the crime scene where matt's
blood was found the burning of the body
at the public incinerator felt a little
too convenient when that went down and i
wouldn't be surprised if that comes back
up again i think what i'll do this week
is follow up with another video in a few
days and start discussing the theories
that are out there now that we have a
lot more information to work with most
of what's been out there so far has been
gut level reactions and guesses but now
i think it's more interesting so i'll
break down the new promo trailer for the
next episode and look at where this
limited series might be heading in the
last six episodes i do have to say i'm
enjoying molly pushing her way into the
middle of things and expect her alliance
with angela to keep things exciting the
character is annoying but it's in a way
that's a nice contrast to the locals
plus she is dexter's worst nightmare in
a lot of ways and i think that's a good
place to leave things let me know in the
comments what you like or dislike about
the series so far which questions do you
think are the most important and what
theories do you have or want to discuss
in the upcoming video please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon